torrential rains and flash floods
sweeping away homes uprooting trees
tearing families apart
at least four children are among the
dozens killed in the u.s state of
kentucky
siblings the oldest eight the youngest
just two
mother nature's fury has left behind
little more than debris and destruction
i had my own life saving saved him
i've got nothing
there weather forecasting models that
governments have used for decades are
obsolete in an ever warming world this
is what the rainy season is going to
look like
with each flood it keeps getting higher
and with each flood we hope that's the
biggest one and it just it never seems
to end
as people try to come to terms with what
they've lost grim predictions and more
warnings from the governor
i'm worried that we're going to be
we're going to be finding bodies for
weeks to come
as people in these areas are looking at
the next couple days make a plan
for sunday afternoon through monday
when the storms leave make sure you are
in a safe place i don't want to lose one
more person
we care about you it's not fair that's
going to rain again but it is
search and rescue operations continue
repairing infrastructure remains a
problem for another day
thousands of people don't have power
shelter or clean water
the appalachian region is home to some
of the poorest communities in america
extreme rain has wreaked havoc on their
doorsteps
people who didn't have much to begin
with have lost everything
zayn basravi al jazeera